the aftermath of another suicide bombing
in Pakistan more than 150 wounded from
the attack at Baja were near the Afghan
borders are rushed to a nearby hospital
on stretchers
the walking wounded are bathed in blood
family and friendship prayers and make a
passionate appeal for peace and security
everywhere the situation is getting
worse No One Is Safe anywhere even in
the mosque school or Bazaar and now it's
the political rallies we don't know who
is responsible for this Menace
the Pakistani military launched several
operations in bordering areas forcing
the Pakistani Taliban to escape into
Afghanistan the Pakistani Fighters have
found Safe Haven across the border
especially since the U.S withdrawal from
Afghanistan two years ago police in
Pakistan say attacks by the Pakistani
Taliban are being carried out from
Afghanistan the presence
of
elements of certain prescribed
organizations
in a neighboring country
adversely affects uh
the Law and Order situation in the earth
while tribal area
police being the front line police
has faced tremendous challenges
but was able to successfully thought
two of these attempts but the leader of
the Jamaica Islam which is part of the
ruling Coalition says the increase in
attacks is also due to the failure of
Pakistan's Security Forces an
intelligence agencies
intelligence there are 26 intelligence
agencies in this country and it's their
failure despite having all resources
they have failed to provide us security
to maintain the peace for how long our
people will become victims of terrorism
senior Army and police officials and
Pakistan acknowledge they cannot win
this war without the help from their
neighbors in Afghanistan the United
Nations security Council has urged
countries to cooperate with Pakistan in
its efforts to apprehend and prosecute
those responsible for the violence many
here say the government needs to focus
more on improving security instead of
settling political scores Pakistani
government leaders have repeatedly
raised a concerns with Afghan Taliban
leaders but after receiving Assurance
sales that Afghan territory will not be
used for attacks Pakistan wants actions
rather than words
foreign